bu
ismim Ceyhun uzatan Turkcell'de
çalışıyorum Sizlerin de bildiği gibi
burada olmaktan çok mutluyum tedavisine
beni davet ettiği için tekrar teşekkür
ediyorum sizlerle paylaşmak istediğim
çok şey var ama süremiz az o yüzden ben
de çok böyle spesifik konularda ziyade
biraz kavramsal konularla ilgili size
aktarımda bulmaya çalışacağım arkadaşlar
tabii Gönül isterdi ki yan yana olalım
aynı odada olalım göz göze bakalım ama
olsun İnşallah bir sonraki etkinlikte
bunuda birlikte yapıyor olalım diyelim
Şimdi arkadaşlar hayat bir yolculuk
Sizler de çok gençsiniz bu yolculuğun
başındasınız çok şanslısınız harika bir
dönem bunu bize de söylemişlerdi
dinlemişti Kama çok da ehemmiyet vermiş
miydik açıkçası çok emin değilim Ama
benim de yeni size söylemek istiyorum
harika bir dönemdesiniz Bunun değerini
bilin O önümüzdeki sizi bekleyen
sürprizlere de hazırlıklı olun inşallah
harika sürprizler sizi bekliyorsun
diyelim şimdi sizle beraber Ben bir
planlama yapmak istiyorum Yani
önümüzdeki yıllığa öyle o güzel
dönemleri birlikte size sizlerle beraber
planlıyorum haber planlamış mıydım
planlamıştım ama 27 senedir iş hayatında
Muhtemelen sizin yaşınızda iki katı
kadar orada gördüklerimi edindikleri mi
biriktirdiklerimi bir paket haline
getirdim ve 10 dakikada size kavramsal
olarak Anlatmaya çalışacağım Arkadaşlar
öncelikle oturum ne dedik amaçlar ve
araçlar bu amaçlar ve araçlar bazen
birbirine karıştırılabilir your ve
amaçlar kısmından önce başlamak
istiyorum Gelin size bir amaç belirliyor
ne hayatımızın gelip geri kalanı için
Önümüzdeki dönemler için bir amaç
belirleyelim şimdi eğer salonda olsaydı
soracaktım arkadaşa Amacınız ne Örneğin
TED Rönesans da okuyorsunuz üniversiteye
gireceksin bir meslek hayatına atacaksın
vs bu Amacınız ne diye sormak istedim
size Muhtemelen ve derdiniz doktor
olacağım işte mühendis olacağım Çok para
kazanacağım harika hayatım olacak falan
filan Öyle değil mi Peki ben bu amaçları
bir an amaçlar oluyor amaçlar olarak
vereyim Bir O ana amaca hizmet eden alt
amaçlar ya da hedefler Bir de bu ikisini
ikisini ulaşmak için kullanacağımız
araçlar şimdi Ulvi amaçla ilgili size
şudur demeden önce bir hikaye anlatmak
istiyorum çok kısa canlılığını Duydunuz
mu burada öğrenci arkadaşlarımız 3-4
tane arkadaşımız var onları soru soruyor
bize çok yanı kim olduğunu biliyor
musunuz Bilen varsa ev Kaldırabilir mi
genç arkadaşlardan bir var arkada harika
bir dost pek bir hızlı plan videosu
duymuş olan var mı Tamam bir iki tane
güzel bence duymadım diyen varsa hemen
Toplantıdan sonra Google'da süresi biraz
baksın şu John arkadaşlar okula gitmiş
John yanında soru Ne demişler ki çok
büyüyünce ne olacaksın John demiş ki ne
demiş Bu mutlu olacağım John Büyüyünce
ne olmak istiyorsun cevap Ben büyüyünce
mutlu olmak istiyorum
Zannederim soruyu yanlış anladım Hayır
Zannederim Siz hayatı yanlış anladınız
canım verdiği cevapta Bu arkadaşlar
Aslında hepimiz mutlu olmak için varız
bütün motivasyonumuz ömrümüz boyunca
hayatımız boyunca mutlu olmak çok mutlu
olmak için de birkaç şehir alt amacı ana
amacımız olarak mutlu olmak ama alta
maçlara baktığımız zaman doğru ve iyi
yapmamız gereken alt başlıkları mız var
Bunlardan bir tanesi çok güzeldi
edilebilir hemen unutulabilir ama
aslında En önemlilerinden bir tanesi
sağlıklı olmamız lazım Öyle değil mi
sağlıklı olmamız lazım Ben sizden
özellikle rica ediyorum arkadaşlar
sağlığınızı Her zaman ön planda tut
sağlık mesleği meniz
bu sporun uzs Uykunuz bakın beslenme
spor uykuya ben daha 12 yaşında 13
yaşındayım Hayır İnanın bana şu andan
başlayan ömrünüzün sonuna kadar o
amaçladığımız Ulvi hedefleri de yerine
getirebilmek için alt amaçlar için de
Öncelikle sağlıklı olmamız lazım
beslenmeniz sporunuzu Uykunuz 3 Sadece
üç tane mi Bir tane daha var arkadaşlar
mutlaka bir hobiniz olsun Bakın ben 47
alttaki gün önce doğum gününde 48 48 yaş
bastım bunları yaşamış bir insan olarak
size söylüyorum mutlaka bir hobiniz
olsun ve mümkünse Biz sanatla ilgilenen
yüzük resim yazmak
dünyanın en güzel ve ihtiyacımız olan
enerji orada fiziksel sağlığınız için
olması gerekenler Tamam ama onu
destekleyecek olan ruh sağlığınız hayat
enerjiniz o hedefleriniz yerine
getirebilecek olan motivasyonumuz
sanatta Allah sana da en azından bir
dalıyla ilgilenen arkadaşlar veya kizin
okuyun ama mutlaka hobi de e çantanızı
Bitene koyun ikinci tarafa gelelim neydi
hatırlatıyorum mutlu olmak istiyoruz
sağlıklı olacağız ikinci şey başarılı
olacağız arkadaşlar başarılı olmamız
lazım insanların hayattaki en büyük
motivasyonu başarılı Olmaktır kendisinin
başarılı olması ya da çok sevdiği değer
verdiği bir grubun ve insanların bir
takımın bir komünitenin başarılı
olmasını önünden Galatasaray döndüm 10
geliyorduk çok mutluydum bir tane gol
yedik sonra 3-4 saat gayet mutsuz geçti
Çok basit bir örnek olarak saklamak
istedim başarılı olmak Peki asıl soru
burada belki de günün en önemli sizler
için de belki faydalı olan alanı nasıl
başarılı olacağız birkaç tane temel
başlık söyleyeceğim Gönül ister ki çok
detayıyla hepsinde ilgili konuşabiliyor
olmak için vakit olsun ama aklınızda kal
O bile benim için çok değerli arkadaşlar
öncelikle başarılı olmak için
sevdiğiniz alanda olmanız lazım
inanılmaz önemli şunun için sıkın bir
alana girmeyin orada Kazan çok daha
fazlaymış bu alan çok popüler herkes şu
yapmak istiyor En Çok övülen yanlış Siz
gönlünüz nerede iyi hissediyorsunuz
kendinizi ne yapmak istiyorsunuz Çünkü
İnanın bana istediğiniz mutlu olduğunuz
Allah'ın sizin en güçlü olduğumuz
alandır ve Oradaki hiçbir iş size zor
gelmez Benim Premium tecrübe ettiğim
konu ve bu işler çok dağınık ve çok
çeşitlidir sizin için sıkıcı olan bir
konu bir başkası için çok değerli bir
alandır eğer o alanda enerjisini sarf
ediyorsa size göre başarılı olma şansı
çok daha yüksektir Bunun için araştırın
en zor kısmı şudur bunu tespit etmek
yani evet ben hangi alana daha eğlenin
yüks Sen hangi alanı daha çok seviyorum
hangi alanda daha başarılı olabilirim Şu
anda Bulunduğunuz nokta derslerinizde de
bunu
öpüşme ötüşmeye çalışabilirim ki Ben
matematikten Çok keyif alıyorum ben
Fizikten Çok keyif alıyorum ben sosyal
bilimlerden veya müzik ve sanatla ilgili
alanlardan Bu size Işık verebilir ama
bunu tespit etmeniz için konuşmanız
görüşmeniz araştırmanız lazım bunu
belirlemeye çalışın Arkadaşlar doğru
alana girerseniz önünüzdeki Hayatının
geri kalan kısmında diğerlerine göre
birkaç adım önde hayata başlamış
olursunuz böyle sevdiğimiz için
yapacağız sevdiğiniz alan odaklanacağız
Bu arada bu çok zor çok kolay değil
Sadece sizinle ilgili dediği sistemle
ilgili ikinci süreceğim şey ise şu bunu
geçmek kendinizi geliştirin diyeceğim
ama kendinizi geliştirin derken de şunu
ekleyeceğim
geçmek için çalışmayın gelişmek için
çalışın yani Örneğin yine okulla ilgili
sizinle ilgili Bu bir dersi geçmek için
elbette günün sonunda geçeceğiz ama o
çok Mekanik bir şey Aslolan öğrenmek
oradaki bilgiyi içselleştirmek çantaya
koymak ileride bunu kullanmak
Dolayısıyla Arkadaşlar lütfen
derslerinizi yarın öbür gün bir işe
başladığınız zaman işteki konuları
geçmek veya bir yere bir Pick atmak için
değil hakikaten öğrenmek ister leştirmek
kendinizle birleştirmek ve ileride
kullanmak için bakın şu fizik ya
inanılmaz ana mesela bilmiyorum
derslerinde birbirine ayrılmak
istemiyorum ortamda ama harika bir alan
muazzam bir şey yani fizikteki olsun ya
Şaşırtıcı sürpriz şeyler ver onu sadece
üçlükten formülü ezberleyin de şu
sınavdaki soru yapayım diye bakmayıp da
gerçekten ya bu Güneş sisteminde bu
gezegenler nasıl dönüyorum merak ederek
o merakla yaklaşırsanız numarasından bir
donanıma sahip olursunuz her alındım ör
ne sürebiliriz Dolayısıyla geçirmek için
değil gelişmek için öğrenin kendini
kendini geliştir başlığında daha sonra
ilişkileri geliştirir bir sevdiğin
alanda ol kendini geliştir ilişkileri
geliştirir Arkadaşlar bir sosyal
varlıklarız toplum içerisinde yaşıyoruz
Hiçbirimiz tek başımıza değil izzu
sosyal alanda da böyledir iş hayatında
da böyle iş hayatında bir yere
varacaksınız ve hayatınızda bir şey
başaracaksınız bir takım olarak
özellikle kurumsal şirketler ve içinde
bulunduğu kurumda takım çok değerlidir
takım olarak hareket ederiz takımın
kadar güçlüsün deriz etrafındakilere
kadar güçlüsün tanıdığın insanlar kadar
güçlüsün ilişkilerin kadar güçlüsün
Dolayısıyla ilişkilerinizi güçlendirin
tanıdığınız insanları ve samimi bir
ilişki kurum ile insanlarla Birbirinize
destek olun ki o komünitenin o ekibin o
takımın gücü çarpan etkisiyle bir artı
bir iki değil üç dört beş haline gelsin
bu ne der ki hayatınızda inanılmaz
destekleyecek çok büyük bir sorunları
aşmak için aylarca uğraşmak yerine
sadece bir telefon açarak birkaç dakika
içerisinde sorunu çözer bildiğiniz
göreceksiniz veya beni bilgiye
ihtiyacımız olduğunda aynı şekilde bunu
yapabileceğinizi göreceksiniz son
başarılı olmak başındaydı hatırlatmak
isterim size mutlu olacağız nasıl
olacağız sağlıklı olacağız başarılı Uzel
Çünkü başarı en büyük Hayat motivasyon
mutluluk motivasyonu nasıl başarılı
olacağız sevdiğimiz alan odaklanacağız
kendimizi geliştireceğiz ilişkilerimizi
geliştireceğiz bir şey daha söyleyeceğim
sizlere arkadaşlar başarısız olmaktan
korkmayacağız Hata yapmaktan asla
korkmayacağız asla bunların hepsini bir
fırsat olarak değerlendireceğiz
yaptığımız hatalardan ve
başarısızlıklardan ders alacağız
döneceğiz nerede hata yaptım diyeceğiz
ve onları işaretleyeceğiz bir sonraki
benzer durumda ortaya yapmayacağız Ve
henüz o tecrübeyi Ne almış ve başarısız
olmamış insanlara göre oldukça tecrübeli
hale geleceğiz bugün dünyada gerek iş
dünyasında olsun gerek spor sana birçok
alandaki en zirvedeki meşhur insanların
pek roundu geçmişi başarısızlıklarla
dolu dur arkadaşlar araştırın bir sürü
başarısızlık hikayesi vardır ama onları
güçlü kılan şey Bu başarısızlıklar
Dolayısıyla sınavda da bu arada
öğretmenlerinden izin alarak söylüyorum
başarısız olmaktan korkmayın başarısız
sanız Eğer mesela üniversite hazırlık
döneminde en çok tavsiye edilen şey bir
soruyu yanlış yaptıysam bir deneme
sınavında en dünyanın en güzel şeyi
Çünkü deneme sınavında yanlış yaptım ve
onu öğrenmek için bir fırsatı var artık
onu öğrenebilirsin günü geldiğinde
benzer bir yatay artık yapmayacaksın
Dolayısıyla başarısızlıktan hiçbir zaman
korkmuyoruz son maddemiz bu alandaki ise
şu
an kontrol edebildiğimiz alanlara
odaklanıyoruz bu hayatı tamamını kontrol
edemeyiz bizim dışımızda olan gelişmeler
var bizim kontrol edebileceğimiz şeyler
var Eğer kontrol edemediğimiz alanlara
odaklanıp enerjimiz oraya sarf edersek
hiçbir işe yaramaz ama o enerjimizle
kontrol edebildiğiniz alanları odaklanır
sako zorluklar içerisinde birçok şeyi
başarma fırsatı elde ederiz Örneğin
pandem işlerimizin kontrolünde değil
kapandı evi ortadan kaldırma şansımız
yok ama oturup pandemi var diye Karalar
bağlamak yerine İçinde bulunduğumuz bu
ortamda nasıl İşimizi gücümüzü sosyal
hayatımızda sürdürebiliriz ve bu dönümü
en iyi şekilde nasıl geçirebiliriz ve
odaklanmak bizim yapabileceğimiz şeyler
konusunda Elimizi güçlendirir ve bugün
de burada olduğu gibi bizi bir araya
getirme şansı verir son başlık ise denge
Hayat dengeden ibaret Arkadaşlar her
zaman aşırı lardan kaçın aşırı
çalışmaktan çok aşırı yemekten aşırı
spor yapmaktan aşırı eylemler başında
aşırı veya fazla varsa bundan
kaçırmamanızı tavsiye ederim Sizlere
hayat Ben gelen ibaret her zaman ben
söylemeye çalışıyorum etrafıma çalışma
zamanı çalışma sonuna kadar dinlenme
zamanı dinlenme eğlenme zamanı eğlenme
bunları birbirine karıştırmayınız sürece
bu başarıya giden yolda yine çok güçlü
olacağınıza sonsuz inancım var En son
kendimden örnek vererek size söylemek
istediğim şey ise şu burada sürede takip
edemiyorum umarım inşallah çıkmışımdır
söyleyeceğim Şu arkadaşlar
bari iş hayatı ile ilgili söyleyip yeni
iş hayatından davet ettiğiniz Bence
birçok şey varsa elbet Ama doğru zamanda
doğru yerde doğru insanlarla olmak çok
kıymetli iyi bir işin içerisinde olmak
çok kıymetli buradaki Doğru zamanla
ilgili size örnek ve de bir bu Müjde
vermek istiyorum açıkçası son olarak
sözlerini bitirmeden önce ben
üniversiteden mezun olduğumda
1995 yılındaydı Hiçbirimiz yoktunuz Bu
da bana çok farklı geliyor tabi 95
yılında mezun oldum
ve işe başladım bir sene bir kurumda
çalıştım daha sonra beni telefonla
aradılar Boğaziçi Üniversitesi mezunlar
derneği dedi ki
mezunu musunuz Yapı Kredi Bankası'nın
iştiraki
internet alanında Superonline isminde
bir şirket kuruyor ve
kadrolarını oluşturmaya çalışıyor
ilgilenir misiniz Ne alanında dedim
internet erişimi evlere kurumlara falan
bebek ki dinleyelim dedim kapattım ama
çok gencim takip eden yeni mezun oldum
ve İnanın bana sokakta yüz tane insan
alalım sırayla soralım İnternet nedir
İnternet nedir diye yüz taneden 99'u
Hiçbir fikrim yok o Çünkü internetin
sözlükteki niz karşılığı bilimsel
makaleler de var ama sosyal hayata
içerisinde yok Üniversite dahil
üniversitelerde Bazı internet
bağlantıları var laboratuvarlarda o
kadar cep telefonu falan hiç o konuya
girmiyorum yani Sizin hepiniz değişik
dünyada doğdunuz Hatta televizyon
Örneğin verebilir Hatta aklıma geldi ve
ilkokuldayken arkadaşlar bizi postaneye
götürdüler
bir sınıf olarak götürme nedenleri
telefon göstermekti ama telefon
bildiğiniz telefonlardan değil sabit ve
çevrilen telefonları bizi diziler 25
kişi hepimiz telefon alarak karşıdakinin
sesini duyduk ne kadar büyük ne kadar
enteresan bir işte onu o zaman yaşadık
Superman Dolayısıyla internet falan yok
Ve ben o işi kabul ettim ve doğru
zamanda doğru yerde olmak var ya
patlamak üzere olan bir sektörde bulunma
şansı edindim internet işi şu anda o
güne kadar içerisinde ve derinin
dolduğunu söylemene hiç gerek yok ama 96
yılında girdiğim sektör bugüne kadar çok
büyük bir hızla büyüdü Ben de o işin
içerisinde oldum çalıştım Elbette Emek
de sarf ettim ve ben de o Şirketle
beraber o sektörle beraber o alanda
kariyerimde bir yere gelme fırsatı elde
ettim ama girdim alan ve sektör bu
şekilde büyüyen bir alanda olmayabilirdi
veya dünya Global anlamda böyle bir
konjonktürde böyle bir ontex içerisinde
olmayabilirdi sizinle açısında iyi haber
ve müjde ise şu benzer bir benzer bir
noktadayız yani endüstri devrimi
Dediğiniz zaman ilk işte su buharı buhar
makinaları bir patlama arkasından
elektrik ve onunla ilgili otomasyon
sistemleri ip atlama onun arkasından
yarıiletkenler bilgisayarlar yeni bir
alan yeni bir sektöre patlama sonra
internet onu ben yakaladım harika Şimdi
arkadaş bu dijital dünyada Yapay Zeka
gibi büyük veri gibi bambaşka bir Sibel
dünyanın içerisine giriyoruz ve bu
dijital dönüşüm gerek kurumların gerek
kişilerin insanların sosyal hayatlarını
iş yapış şekilleri yaşamış şekillerini
temelinden değiştiriyor ve Sizde tam
bunun başlangıcında sınız bu
söylediğimden lütfen biz Efendim Teknik
bir konuda da kariyer sahibi olmamız
gerekiyor algılamayın bunun teknik
ticari sosyal Akademi birçok alanda
etkisi var ama söylemek istediğim şey şu
değişen mi dünyanın en başındasınız ve
bunun içinde siniz bunun içinde doğdunuz
bizim gibi olmayan bir noktadan sonra
dahil olmanız içerisindesiniz çok şanslı
olduğumuzu düşünüyorum Bu açıdan
Dolayısıyla sizlere hayatınızın geri
kalanında büyük mutluluklar başta onun
içinde büyük başarılar diliyorum Çok
teşekkür ederim dinlediğiniz için
abone ol
[Müzik]